TOMORROW AFTERNOON.
>> Sandra: THIS JUST IN.
NEW WEEKLY JOBLESS NUMBERS
SHOWING 840,000 AMERICANS
APPLIED FOR UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS LAST WEEK ALONE.
WHITE HOUSE ECONOMIC ADVISOR
LARRY KUDLOW JOINS US NOW.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU, LARRY.
ALWAYS APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
WHAT DOES THIS NUMBER TELL YOU
ABOUT HOW THIS ECONOMIC
RECOVERY IS GOING?
BECAUSE THAT’S STILL -- THAT
NUMBER HOVERS AT AN HISTORIC
HIGH FOR THIS COUNTRY.
AS OF THIS MORNING, 29 WEEKS
SINCE THE CORONAVIRUS LOCKDOWNS
BEGAN THE NUMBER TOTALS 63
MILLION.
THAT WORKS OUT TO 40% OF THE
U.S. LABOR FORCE.
THIS IS A LOT OF AMERICANS
STILL HURTING AS A RESULT OF
THIS PANDEMIC.
>> I DON’T DENY THAT A LOT OF
AMERICANS ARE STILL HURTING.
I THINK THERE IS STILL A LOT OF
HARDSHIP OUT THERE.
I DO WANT TO NOTE THESE WEEKLY
UNEMPLOYMENT CLAIMS HAVE FALLEN
SHARPLY FROM THE PEAKS
REGISTERED IN MID TO LATE
APRIL, EARLY MAY.
THEY HAVE BEEN TRENDING LOWER
NOW FOR FIVE MONTHS.
I ALSO WANT TO ADD TO THAT,
SANDRA, CONTINUING CLAIMS WHICH
IS THE ACTUAL PAYMENTS, NOT THE
APPLICATIONS BUT THE PAYMENTS
FELL SHARPLY BY OVER 1 MILLION.
THAT NUMBER IS USUALLY A PRETTY
GOOD FORECASTER OF THE NEXT
MONTH’S JOB.
SO I THINK LABOR SITUATION IS
LOOKING MUCH BETTER.
WE’RE MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
I MIGHT ADD 2/3 OF THE RETURN
JOBS COME FROM THE LOWER WAGE
END SO WE’RE PROSPERING THERE.
IT IS A TOUGH BATTLE.
IT IS NOT GOING TO BE DONE JUST
IN FIVE MONTHS AFTER THE
TERRIBLE PANDEMIC CONTRACTION
AND ALL THAT WENT WITH IT.
THE REALITY IS THE ECONOMY IS
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION AND
STILL LOOKS TO ME VERY MUCH
LIKE A V-SHAPED RECOVERY.
YOU’LL HAVE A HUGE NUMBER FOR
Q3 GDP.
WE’VE BEEN SAYING 20% PLUS.
THE FED AND OTHERS AND GOLDMAN
SACHS SAYING 35%.
HOUSING BOOM, AUTO BOOM,
RETAILING BOOM, MANUFACTURING
BOOM GOING ON TO RESTOCK
INVENTORIES.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE ALL THE
NUMBERS YOU SEE A STRONG
SELF-SUSTAINING RECOVERY.
I STILL THINK WE SHOULD HAVE
SOME OF THE TARGET ASSISTANCE
PACKAGES THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND STEVE MUTSCHIN ARE TALKING
ABOUT.
THE ECONOMY IS IN HAVE GOOD
FOOTING AND RECOVER EVERYTHING
FASTER THAN ANYBODY THOUGHT.
EVEN THE FEDERAL RESERVE HAS
UPPED ITS ECONOMIC GROWTH
FORECAST FOR THE SECOND HALF OF
THIS YEAR AND EARLY NEXT YEAR.
>> Sandra: I WANT TO POINT OUT
THE NEW CLAIMS ARE THE LOWEST,
ALTHOUGH STILL VERY HIGH, THE
LOWEST SINCE MARCH 14th.
THE CONTINUING CLAIMS YOU POINT
OUT, ANOTHER IMPORTANT NUMBER,
ALMOST 11 MILLION BUT STILL THE
LOWEST SINCE MARCH 28th, LARRY.
THE PRESIDENT JOINED MARIA
BARTIROMO ON FOX BUSINESS AND
ASKED WHY HE ENDED THOSE
STIMULUS TALKS KNOWING SO MANY
PEOPLE STILL NEED HELP
INCLUDING AMERICAN BUSINESSES.
HERE WAS HIS RESPONSE.
>> President Trump: SHUTDOWN
TALKS TWO DAYS AGO BECAUSE THEY
AREN’T WORKING OUT.
IT WASN’T THE WORKERS FAULT OR
AIRLINES FAULT THAT CHINA DID
THIS.
>> Sandra: LARRY, YOU ARE
ADVISING THE PRESIDENT.
YOU SEE WHAT’S HAPPENING IN THE
ECONOMY.
CAN YOU TELL THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE THAT SOMETHING GETS DONE
BEFORE ELECTION DAY?
DOES IT?
>> I WOULD LIKE TO.
I DON’T THINK THE RECOVERY
ITSELF DEPENDS ON THE SO-CALLED
ASSISTANCE PACKAGE.
HOWEVER IMPORTANTLY WE HAVE
MADE TARGETED PLEAS FOR
ASSISTANCE IN KEY AREAS AND NOW
THE PRESIDENT BELIEVES WE
SHOULD SHIFT INTO A STAND-ALONE
BILL TO GET THE KEY POINTS
THROUGH.
THE BIG PACKAGE HAD WAY TOO
MUCH SPENDING FOR STATE AND
LOCAL BAIL-OUTS.
ENDED THE HYDE AMENDMENT.
FEDERAL FUNDING FOR ABORTION.
ADDITIONAL HEALTHCARE FOR
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
A WHOLE BUNCH OF THINGS IN
THERE THAT HAD NOTHING TO DO
WITH COVID OR ECONOMIC RECOVERY.
NOW WE’VE BEEN ASKING SECRETARY
MNUCHIN DOING A GREAT JOB OF
DIFFICULT NEGOTIATIONS.
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE SOME
UNEMPLOYMENT ASSISTANCE.
WE HAD AN EXECUTIVE ORDER BUT
THAT WON’T LAST FOREVER.
WE NEED CONGRESS FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT ASSISTANCE.
LIKE TO EXTEND THE PPP SMALL
BUSINESS LOANS.
MONEY LEFT OVER, $135 BILLION.
LET’S USE IT.
THE PRESIDENT HAS SIGNED OFF ON
THE ASSISTANCE CHECKS.
THEY WILL BE DIRECT MAIL.
WE NEED LEGISLATION TO DO THAT.
WE ALSO WANT TO HELP THE KIDS
GET BACK TO SCHOOL AND MAKE THE
SCHOOLS AS SAFE AS POSSIBLE.
NOW, THOSE ARE JUST VITAL
TARGETED ASSISTANCE AREAS THAT
WOULD STRENGTHEN THE ECONOMY,
DEAL WITH COVID, AND HELP THOSE.
YOU MENTIONED BEFORE CORRECTLY
THERE IS A LOT OF FOLKS
UNEMPLOYED AND A LOT OF
HARDSHIP.
>> Sandra: THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
ISSUE.
>> LET’S HELP THEM IN A
TARGETED WAY.
>> Sandra: I HAVE LIMITED TIME.
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE THIS ON
THE DEBATE STAGE.
THE PRESIDENT SAID VIRTUAL NO
THANK YOU.
DO YOU THINK HE SHOULD STILL DO
THE DEBATE EVEN IF IT’S VIRTUAL?
>> I THINK YOU’LL SEE A
RENEGOTIATION OF THAT.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT IS
GETTING WELL.
HE WILL PASS THE TEST AND WILL
BE SHOWING NEGATIVE TESTING, SO
I’M NOT SURE THAT’S GOING TO
HAPPEN.
I DO WANT TO SAY, SANDRA, IT IS
SO IMPORTANT TO ME.
MIKE PENCE SHOWED LAST NIGHT IN
THE DEBATE, WHICH HE WON GOING
AWAY, IN A CALM MANNER HE TOOK
COMMAND OF THE DEBATE AND
CRUCIALLY TIME AND AGAIN
POINTED OUT THE KEY DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN BIDEN-HARRIS AND
TRUMP-PENCE ON TAXES, ON
REGULATIONS, ON ENERGY, ON
SOCIALIZING AND NATIONALIZING
HEALTHCARE.
TOUGH ON CHINA AND GOOD TRADE
DEALS.
AND, OF COURSE, RIGHT TO LIFE
AND STACKING THE SUPREME COURT.
HE MADE THIS SO CLEAR.
DIFFERENCES MATTER, OKAY?
YOU HAVE A VERY EXTREMIST
LEFT-WING DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATE
AND YOU’VE GOT A GOOD
MAINSTREAM CONSERVATIVE
CANDIDATE WHO BY THE WAY
INCREASED LIVING STANDARDS BY
FIVE TIMES AS MUCH IN THREE
YEARS AS THE  OBAMA PEOPLE DID
IN EIGHT YEARS.
I WANT HIM ON MESSAGE AND I
WANT HIM TO SHOW THE
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN THE TWO
TEAMS AS MIKE PENCE DID
BRILLIANTLY YESTERDAY.
BY THE WAY, MIKE PENCE LOOKED